よろしくお願いします
まあ今日のあのまああまりあの深い仏教の中身には入りませんですけど
まあ何回何回もまた繰り返しているテーマでもありますけどね
でもこの宣伝文句を読むと
まあなんかどうまとめればいいかっていう
ちょっと疑問もできますけどね
まあいろんなところを喋りすぎて
まあ一応あの 焦点を当てようとしているのは
この物事を変えるべきかないか
変えられるかないかというところなんですね
まあそれが必要だと昔の人が思っていたことを証明するために
このまあこのキリスト教のこのお祈り文句を入れてるんですけど
ですから その祈り文句の中の意味も
やっぱりこの個人がまあ物事を変えたいんですね
でも勇気がない それから何を変えたら方がいいか
何を変えてはいけないかということの識別もない状態を泣いてるんですね
で まあ祈りっていうのは
まあ仏教から言えば やっぱりまあ希望を言ってることで
まあちょっと悪口と言えば泣いてるんですけどね
この希望を語る言葉っていうのは
もうかなりどんな人間にもすぐ感動的でインパクト強く心に響くんですよ
だからまあどんな宗教でもこの祈り文句っていうのは大変もう感動的だと思ってるんですね
ヒンドゥー教でもこのタマソマジョーティルガメとかね
大変有名な文句で みんなすっごい大事に愛情を持って覚えている言葉なんですね
暗闇から光へ導いたまえという意味なんですね
まあヒンドゥー教はまあもう同じくこの知恵っていうものが必要だと言ってるんですからね
まあそれ仏教の知恵とは違いますけどね
その場合も まあ自分で地を切り開くんじゃなくて
光へ導いたまえと なんかすごいかっこよさそうに聞こえるんですけどね
だから待ってるんですよ
誰か引っ張ってくれるまで
押してくれるまで で  それは一つまあ人間の弱みでね
誰か尻を叩いてもう動かせないと動かない
そのまんまいる まあそれはまあどんな人間にも大体はあることで
ですから まあ他に頼ると祈りということがね
まあ一応まあなかなか社会から離れなくなっちゃいますね
で 人間の本来の弱みですから
でお釈迦様もやっぱり人を後ろから激しく叩いてるんですよ
歩けと 動けと で まあその場合はこの祈りとは違うんですね
ものすごい具体的で 現実的に
まあ心をまあ叩いちゃうんですね
いわゆるまあ 心立てるのではなくて
まあ一応まあ現実的に人々を戒めているんですね
それから物事をまあ変えるべきかというポイントについて考えてみましょう
まあ私たち生きてるこの現代世界では
激しく物事が変わっていくんですね
それでだいたいまあまあ年取っている人々以外はね
みんな物事をもう激しく
もう変え 変えたくて 変えたくて
もう大変もういら立っているというかね
落ち着いてないんですね
とにかく変えようと それからまあ若い人々の間では
この変えたということ
新しいやと流行やと そういう言葉も大変かっこいい言葉になっているんですね
ですから もうあんたちょっと古いんじゃないかなという一言葉は
もうちょっと人をおバカにして言ってる言葉なんですね
もう古すぎやと という一言葉だけも
ですから この世の中ではみんなこの変わること
何か新しくすること 大変かっこいいんだと
そう思っているんです
だから 変えるべきかということは
それで 問題にはなりますね
なぜかというと この現代
我々の世界ではとにかく変えればいいんですよ
ただそれだけで まあそれだけちょっと理解しておけば
もうかなり現代的で流行に乗っているというか
流行を先取りしている人になるんですよ
もう何でもいいんです
あるものはちょっと変える
それだけ それで変えてからは
もう良くなろうか悪くなろうか
それは関係ないんです
ただ変えればそれが流行なんですね
今思い出すのはもうかなりもう
もう今から見れば私にとってかなり前なんですけど
このイギリスでなんか流行があったんで
みんな頭は両側剃っちゃうんですね
剃って前なんかニワトリの頭の上にあるもののように伸ばしておいて
これまた真っ赤な色で染めて染めちゃうんですね
真っ赤とか青とかね 緑とか
で 両側がもう全部剃るんです
随分それ流行ったんですけど
日本でもまあ若い人々はそれやっていましたしね
それでまたそれ変わったんですね
だからそれでいいかどうか
そうではなくて ただ変えればいいということだけなんですね
なので 服のことを見ても
とにかく変えればいいんです
それであのいろいろこのファッションショーというんでしょうかね
ありますね テレビで放映してますから
見てください あんなものを着て人の前に出られますかね
時々何かこの大きな猿を被ったようなスカートもあるし
何かビニール袋に入ってビニールビニールで作った服のようなものもあるし
お尻なんかほとんど外へ出して歩く見えるように丸出しの服もデザインの
それまた世界一流のデザイナーだそうですね
で 億万長者だけにね だからこの結局はみんな変えればいいという思考でいるんですよ
悲しいことは それにもみんなすごい苦労しているんですね
だから変える場合 例えばこちら
この水がありますね ペットボトル
これをこうやって 普通だったらもう横に立っておくのは常識ですけどね
これをただこうやってしておけば
それ変えただけなんですね
それは流行ってるんだぞと
別に考える必要ないんですよ
それでまたもう 2 3ヶ月とかになっちゃうと
これまた積まれなくなったら
こうやって蓋を下にして立てるようにすれば
もう変えてるんですね
でもそれでもちょっとやばいぞと
倒れそうだったらまた何か発明するんですね
この倒れないようにすると
またそれは面白く面白くないと思っちゃったら
またもうこういう風にするようにします
変えるっていうことはそんなもんなんですけどね
それほどもう大したことではありません
今 ご飯を食べる場合は
デザートは最後に食べますけどね
もっと流行を思う デザート先に食べても何が悪いんですか？それも変えることなんですよ
それはなんとか流とか言ってね
で 何か新しい名前でもつけて
もうデザートを先に食べると
それから逆順番で食べるんだよと言えば
それもまあ変えることで
例えば日本でお箸でご飯召し上がりますけど
なんでお箸とフォークだけ使うようにしないんですか？だからフォークだったらナイフつなげますけど
もうそれでフォークとナイフでなければあかん
そうじゃなくて なんでフォークとお箸で食べて悪いんですかね
それも変えることだから
だからまあそういうなんか自信ないでしょうね
変えるためには そういう風に変え方には
だからこの変えることは流行だとね
すごいもう飛んでる人々やとものすごい現代的と言うんだけど
結局は片っ端から何でも変える自信はないんです
まだ怯えているんです
なんでそんな情けないかと思いたいんだけどね
だからこの世の中の人々はとにかくものを変えるんだけど
それでいろいろ心の中で葛藤があったり
もういろんなことを考えたりして
うまく変えることさえできないんですね
それでいろんな苦労して苦労して
もう精神的にもうボロボロ状態になるまで苦労して
考えて なんとかちょっとわずかに変えると
別に誰もそれ変えたことに何も文句を言うわけじゃないんですけど
だから私が言いたいのは
変えるということはとても簡単なことなんですけど
なんでそんな苦労するんですかと
だって今まで変えて世界を変えてきたものにしたっても
別に人間に人類に吸ってついて良い結果出しましょうとと思って変えたわけじゃないでしょうに
とにかく何かする それだけのことでしたから
ほとんどひどい結果になってしまったでしょうに
いろんな病気が出てくるわ
自然を破壊するわ まあ体はおかしくなるわね
そういうことになってるんだから
ただみんな変えればいいという話で生きているんですね
だったら いとも簡単にもう変えて変えてしまえばいいんですけど
それはできないところは何でしょうかと
それが一つ大変大事な問題なんですよ
いくら人間がやっぱり流行だ
新しいデザインだ 新しいファッションだ
新しい食べ物だとかね
と 何て言いますか 自慢したいんだけど
どこかで心の中でものすごい思い
思いを持ってるんです
なかなか動かないんです
結局私に言えるのは この流行に走って飛んでいて
これが現代的だという人々も徹底的な保守主義で
もう すごい古臭い考え方にもう縛り付けられ
縛りつけて いるんだということなんです
正直じゃないんです だからこの
まあ我々古い人間がね
まあまあ古くてね 何も変えることはもう好きじゃないなと
もうすごく悪口言われるでしょうしね
まあそれはそれでいいんですよ
もう別にもうもうもう変えなくたってもいいんですからね
まあまあ放っておいてくださいと
年取ってる人のことは
では 若い層の方々はそれほど自由に
生きてるかというと 我々より不自由なんですよ
思考は不自由 生き方は不自由
いろんな概念 いろんな思考概念
固定概念 いろんな決める決まり
自分で作っては作っては
それに束縛されちゃって自由がないんです
そこが考えてほしいポイントなんですよ
変えればいいというならば
私が言うのは変えると
それだったら そんな難しくないんだと
もうとっくに形できてるんだから
それ変えるだけだから
それに何の創造性もインスピレーションも要りません
何かインスピレーション必要ですかね
このペットボトルを横に倒しておくことには
何もいらんでしょうに
もうすでに形決まってるんだから
立って立たせておくという
まあですから まあ変えることは難しいということは
まあまあズボンはね 頭で頭からもう履くことはちょっと無理ですけどね
シャツはもう足からもう
もう穿けてみるとかね
だからズボンは上とシャツは下
そこまで変えることはちょっと構造上無理ですけど
ほんのちょっと考えればそれもできますよ
また切ってちょっと塗り直せばできるんだから
だから自分の国で この自分が学生の時はね
まあ時々もう人をからかう時はね
まあいい加減なことを言ったりすると
まあ一つことわざみたいなものを我々作ったものを言うんですよ
あんたのズボンを頭から脱がしてやり
脱がしてやるぞと それは無理だからね
そんなこと言うと ズボンは頭から脱がしてやるぞと
だからズボンは下へ脱ぐんであっても
頭からは無理ですからね
だからまあ その言葉にしても
やっぱりもう変えることを考えて言ってるんです
で 私が言うのは それはなんで実行できないですかね
頑張れば実行できます
ズボンもシャツと同じく上から脱ぐように作ればいいんだから
簡単でしょうに 下にジップでもつけておけば
それだけでね 脱げますよ
ですから 変えるということは
まあそんなに大した大変なことということではないんです
我々老人の人々はそれにびっくりする人
悩む必要も何もないんですよ
どんなアホな人にもできることなんですね
だからそれは問題ないんだけど
問題がなんでそんなに変えることにはすごい苦労しているんですかと
ほんのわずかでも 何か世界にあることを変えるためには
もう苦労というとも並ならぬ苦労
なんでしょうかね それが
言ってはいけない例なんですけど
このテーラワーダ協会の組織やらいろいろね
新しい活動やら どうしようかというと
私はもう大胆な意見を言いますよ
それの一方的な意見は良くないんだからね
じゃあみんなの意見はいかがでしょうかと
まあ一応聞くんだけど
ろくな意見は言ってくれないということを知ってるんです
なぜかというと この新しくもののことを考えることはものすごい難しいんですよ
心には どこかでこの巨大な山にもものすごい鎖で
もう足の先から頭のてっぺんまで縛りつけてるような感じなんですよ
その中でちょっと指ぐらい変わってるんですよ
人間の生き方っていうのは
そうやって大きな ものすごい強い柱にもずっと鎖で縛ってるんですね
そこでちょっとまぶたぐらい閉じ閉じるとかね
ちょっと指ぐらいちょっと動かせるぐらいね
変えるのはそんなもんなんですよ
だからそういう風に何か意見を言ってくださいと言ったら
あのもう古い古い もう日本の仏教の習慣とかね
なんとかあるある大乗仏教の何かの宗派の考え方とか持ってきて
こういう風にやるんではないか
なんであんた方はそうするんでしょうかと
話にならんでしょうね
そんなことは 古い方法に変えたっても
だから古い伝統的な教えで
なかなか現代時代に意味がないんだから
私はブッダの教えを教えているんであって
このブッダが教えてなかった教え
いろんな人々が好き勝手に喋ったものはどうせ古臭いんですよ
時代は後かもしれません
お釈迦様が亡くなって 600年経ってから人々が作った教えかもしれませんだけど
もう普通の人間が書いた経典だから
もう古臭いんです ブッダの教えとは桁違うんです
だからそれは世界で古くなっちゃって
有効期限がなくなっちゃうんですね
賞味期限が消えているんです
それで賞味期限がもうとっくに消えている
もうもう 400年も消えてるんですから
じゃあ賞味期限は消え切れない話をしようではないかと
するとまたあれを持ってくるという
やっぱりそこで何が理解できるかというと
この我々にとってはこの変えるということは大変難しくなっているんですね
そこで仏教の歴史から見ると
お釈迦様が当時にあった思考体系
それから習慣 全部変えちゃったんです
人間に想像できないほど変えてしまったんです
それはほとんどの人々には理解できなかったんですね
あまりにもこの変化があまりにも早すぎて
もう流行に乗ることができなかったんですね
そこで その仏教という流行に乗る乗り遅れた人々が
もう師匠はわからない
生き方がわからない それで自分たちでまた新しい思想を書くんですよ
作るんですね 作って 我々はこういう風にやるんだぞと
それでお釈迦様は比丘たちに出家者たちに新しい生き方を教えたんですね
それが無理な人々が まあ古い方法へ帰りますと
言って もう何も戒律も生き方も守らないことは素晴らしく素晴らしいことやと
一般の人々とごちゃ混ぜになって
もうみんなと欲に溺れて生活すること
これこそ菩薩行だと 結局何をしたんですかね
お釈迦様が新しい生き方を教えたのに
元に戻っただけなんです
例えば 一般的に言えば
戒律という生き方を設定したのに
それは捨てて 何もない
いい加減な欲に溺れて生活する生き方をまた
葬られているものはまた掘り返して持って来る
教えとしても誰にも頼るなかれと
騙されちゃいますよ 自分には自分しかないんだぞと
自分のことを一番心配するのは自分でしょうと
だったら自分の面倒は自分で見なさいという教えがものすごい最新型の教えなんですよ
それは今もこの世の中で機能していないんです
今になっても 今の現代人も
この 21世紀の この IT 時代の
というふうって自分のことを威張っているでしょうに
私は批判的に言うんですけど
この 21世紀の IT 時代の人々も
結局は他に頼ることが生き方やと思っているでしょうに
で 中国にあるアメリカのスパイ飛行機を着陸したっていうんですね
緊急着陸 それで 24人の人々は後々アメリカに戻ったら
BBC とか またアメリカのテレビ放送局ですね
BBC はイギリスですけど
全部どちらで見ましたけどね
その人々をインタビューするんですね
もうかなり何かまあ言うことからね
全部もう厳しく叩き込まれているなということは見えたんだけどね
普通のアメリカ人の若者の明るさも
まあいい加減さもふざけてしゃべることも何もない
だからこういう風に聞いたらこういう風に答えろと叩き込まれたと思いますけどね
ですから このアメリカの方が一般のね
まあ人々に感情を引き起こすために何か言ってほしいんですね
だから自分たちがもうこの世の中でないほど精神的にいじめられたとかね
拷問されたとかね やっと命拾いしたというような感じであった方が
あのもう単純なアメリカの人々には理解しやすいんですよ
では あんまり現代そんなことは起きませんだからね
もうただまあそこまでだけでね
普通にいただけで 電子メールを送ったりとか
アメリカの家族に手紙を出したりとかね
毎日コンタクト取ったりしていたんだからね
それであなたはその時はどういう精神状態でしたかと
何を考えたんですか？と言ったら
年下の若い人がこう言うんですね
やっぱり家族っていうのはいかにありがたいかと思ったんでしょうと
ですかと それから人っていうのは神様を信じるべきですよと
神様を信じることはいかに大事ですかと思いますかと
という答えなんです だから私は
これであなた 現代人 世界の若者かと
これで最新型の軍事飛行機
飛行機なんか操って 人のスパイ活動をする
もう一番最新 に走っている人ですか？と
ただの田舎のもう一人のアホではないかと
と自分が勝手に思っただけで
あれには聞こえなきゃなんて
どうしてもロジクス成り立たないんですね
それでなんで神様を信じることでことは大変ありがたいとわかるんですかね
逆に神様は全く信じない中国人が着陸許可したことで命を助けたんですけど
着陸拒否したらどうなるんですかね
どうなるんでしょうかね
終わりでしょうに だから論理的に考えれば
これはどんな国が悪いか
それは私たちに関係ないことだから
ただ このちょっとした最近のニュースだからね
私はただただ論理的に考えるだけ
もし中国が厳しい共産圏だからね
もう着陸拒否と入ったら撃つぞと言ったら
海に行かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
行って着陸の代わりに墜落いたしますと
あるいは中国人が着陸許可したのは
もう神様に脅されたんだからと
神様に脅迫されちゃって
我々は怯えて一応着陸は許可しましたと
一人でも行ったならば
やっぱり神様を信じることは大変ありがたいと
と言ってもいいんだけど
そういう証拠は何もなくて
まあふざけて考えちゃうと
着陸許可したんだから
中国に今の飛行機はもうまた返してないしね
今もそのままあるみたいですけど
で まあそんなもんだと思いますけどね
ですから まあ人間っていうのは不思議なもので
あの今になっても お釈迦様みたいな
この大胆なことを言う話は理解さえもできないんですよ
理解さえもできない 自分に頼ると
だからずっとこの原始時代から猿人というかね
あの猿人というんですか
プリマーツという あの猿が人間に成りかかっている
その時からも他人に頼って
木を拝んで山を拝んで生きてきたんだからね
助けてくれと 病気治してくれと
今になっても変わってないんですよ
人格は それで私が言いたいのは
仏教徒に向かって 仏教に向かってね
古いと言うなよと もうかなりひどいものをことを言われるんだよと言ったら
だから人間というのは
この物事を新しく変えるんだ
変えるんだと言ったっても
結局何を 何をなさっているんでしょうかね
何も変わってないんです
結局は まあ変わっているといえば
まあもう建物を作るとかね
まあ工学的なね まあ発展がありますから
まあ服のものもね 素材が変わるとか
まあそれぐらいのことでしょうね
着るものは変わるとかね
乗り物が変わるとか 人が変わらないんですよ
で そこは何でポイントにしたんでしょうかというと
この変わりたくない 変えたくないという
この頑固さ その硬さが生まれてからもあるんです
我々は柔らかくはないんです
柔軟性がないんです とにかく本当のところが変わることが嫌なんです
変わることがてってもう徹底的に嫌がっちゃうんです
嫌がって やっぱり世界変えなくてはいけませんとまた言う
それで生きていられますかね
心の中はもうものすごい
ものすごいきつくて もう徹底的に頑固で硬くて
柔軟性が全くなくて でも口先で変えましょう
変えましょうと言う それも自分たちが口先で言ってるだけやということもわからないんです
本心やと勘違いしている
この葛藤 この矛盾 この偽善を背負って人類は幸せやと思いますかね
楽だと思いますかね だからどちらかはっきりした方がすごく楽なんですよ
例えば おじいちゃん おばあさま方側はもう頑固で
孫たちにあっち行けと
あんた言うこと聞かんぞと
楽にいるんですよ 例えばおじいちゃんも心臓が弱いんだから
朝早く起きてもう走るなよと言っても走る
いくら言ってももう病気だから
もう血圧高いんだからね
こんな食べ物食べるなよと言ったら
ああそうですかと言って
家で食べさせないんだったら外へ行って食べる
それでその人が生き方は楽なんですよ
別にそれで廃人になっても
楽に生きている だから頑固さが
でも正直で 私は頑固やと思ったら
あの葛藤が消えちゃうんですよ
心の中でむやみやたむやむや状態がなくなっちゃうんです
しっかりするんですね
その分は楽なんですね
頑固さ 正しいということではないんだけど
で 一般の人々 多くの人々っていうのは
だから今のおじいちゃんおばあさま方にも頑固になれないんですよ
なりたくてなりたくても
なぜかというと もう最初から批判されているんだから
だから頭の悪い孫たち
言うことばっかり聞いて
それに合わせようとして骨折れてしまっちゃうんです
ですから まあ頑固はいいわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱりそれでも葛藤がない方がいいんじゃないかなと
一般の世界は すべてのみんなは
やっぱりそのものすごい激しい
この矛盾といえば矛盾であって
偽善でいえば偽善であって
そういう生き方をしているんですね
だから全く正直ではありませんね
それで我々には一歩一歩歩むこと
人生を歩むことは大変な苦労なんです
ヒマラヤの頂上のところで歩くことと同じなんですよ
エベレストの上の方に行ったら
ほんのちょっとしかない
登るところは でも一方でもものすごい大変なんです
登るのは それぐらい私たちの生き方が苦しくなってるんですね
ですから それはどういうことかというと
口先でもう変えますよと
なんでも我々は現代人だよと
今は 21世紀ですよと
今は IT 時代ですよとか言いながら
結局は原始人には変わりはありません
人格はね だからちょっと面白おかしく想像してみてください
原始人一人連れてきて
この世の中でちょっと楽な世界ですよ
この日本の社会は コンビニなんか 24時間やってますからね
森に入って獲物を取って焼いて食べる必要ないんだよと言って
原始人一人 この東京どこかにもう入れてみた
想像してください どうなるんでしょうかと
その人にとっては 森の中にいるよりも
もう危険しか何もない
食べるものっていうのは全くもない
大変苦しいんですよ だから我々も精神的に原始人で
この表面的なところで現代人で生きるということは大変な苦しい生き方だと思います
それが仏教で言いたいポイントなんですよ
だから 残念なことに ブッダの話っていうのは随分現代的なんです
だからみんな納得いかない
私に対していろいろ文句を言う
でも皆様が想像している頭の中でイメージしているお坊さんとは違うんですね
実際のブッダの弟子たちが
もう別にみんなを優しい言葉をかけてかけて慰めてあげて
おだててあげて いい格好をつけようということはほとんどないと思いますけど
それはケースバイケースでまあやるかもしれません
だけど一般的にはあまりやらないですね
ですから こういう激しく喋るということは
この私だけの特色というよりも
仏典を読んでみると もうものすごい激しいんですよ
それはいくら日本訳しても読まないことは大変ありがたい助け
救いになってます あるいは読んでも
自分の今までの固定概念で読むんだから
頑固な心で読んでるんだから
心は変化しませんだからね
読んで落ちるんだからね
読んでみてください もう本当に
ちょっと意味をじんみして
かなり鋭く激しく言ってます
一つ例を言います お釈迦様はカースト制度を壊しちゃったんですね
そんなものはもうあまりにもおかしいんだと
人類っていうのは一緒でよと
ワンスペーシスだよと
いわゆるこの犬がいて
猫がそれは 2種類ですよ
で 動物たちね  4つの足で走る動物たちがいて
鳥たちがいて また蛇たちがいるとかね
そうやっていろいろカテゴリーがあるんだよと
でも人間っていうのはカテゴリー一つですよと
すごい科学的に言うんですよ
お釈迦様のそれの理由は
どんな人間に見ても 食べ
食べるもの同じで 生き方が同じで
子供 はっきりとそう言うんですよ
子供の育ち方同じです
産み方同じですと 成長の過程をみんな同じですと
ですから その小学生でね
動物のことを勉強すると
そこら辺でしょ どのように生まれるかと
幼虫の時代 どういうふうなものかと
成虫になったらどういうふうなことですかと
交尾はどういう風にするんですかと
これで寿命はどれぐらい
それでカテゴリーに入れちゃいますから
お釈迦様はそういう枠でカテゴリーに入れたら
人間というのは一つしかいません
だからあなた方は全くアホなことを言っているんだと
嘘を語っているんだと
カースト制度で神様が人間の区別を作ったんだそうと
そんな区別はないんだと
どう見ても 嘘を言うなよという立場で語ったんだけど
それでもあるバラモンがお釈迦様に攻撃しちゃったんですね
あんたは不可触民族でハゲ頭で
あの欲も偉大なる神の子たるバラモン人たちをね
批判するんだと言ったら
お釈迦様はすごい丁寧に答えたんだけど
お釈迦様の論点は あなた方バラモン人は犬より以下ですよと
こういう論理で言ったんですよ
言ったらお釈迦様はこう言うんです
私はすべてのバラモン人を批判しませんと
私はすごい道徳のある行儀のいい
心を清らかにしている人々は
たとえバラモン人であろうが何人であろうが批判しませんよと
それで私が知ってますよと
昔々のバラモン人たちがもう金儲かることは考えなかったんだと
お金を集まることはしなかったんだと
そこで昔の犬たちも金儲けを金儲けようとしなかったんだと
でも今のあなた方は朝から晩まで人から金を奪って金儲かることしか考えていないんだと
でも今の犬も昔と同じく未だに金儲けしませんよと
だから今のバラモンたちは犬よりは以下ですよと
それで昔のバラモンたちがすごい欲が少なくて
女性のところに行ったならば
それは子孫を作る目的だけで
欲に溺れようとではなくて
女の人をもう何とかしようということではなくて
やっぱり子孫を作っていかないとよくないんだという大変大事な仕事として
自分の同じバラモン人の女の人を嫁にもらったんだと
それで子孫を作って それでも欲を捨てたんだと
昔の犬も同じで 交尾するのは子孫を作る時だけですよと
好き勝手に犬を追っかけていかないんだと
それで犬はメス犬と一緒しか一緒になりませんと
豚とかね 山羊とかね そういう動物を追っていかないんだと
でも今のバラモン人はどうですかと
好き勝手に もうカーストも何も気にしないで
気に入っている女の人を奪って犯してるんではないかと
でも犬は未だにあの道徳を守っているんだよ
ですから あなた方の生き方は犬より以下ですよと
そういう風にも激しい批判ですよ
これは当時インドでこの宗教家として拝まれてる人々に対して向かっても
あなた方よりは犬の方が素晴らしいですよということはね
いかにきつい言葉といえばね
だからお釈迦様も別に言いたいことはおっしゃいますからね
まあそういうポイント
でもですから この 仏教というそのものが本当にすごい
この この新しく物事を変化する
には決して反対ではありません
決して反対ではありません
逆に言うのは あんた方には何もできませんと
物事を新しく改良することは
だからあんた方は苦しんで悩んでいるんだよと
新しいアイディア 新しい真理と言ったら
あんた方はもうボケーっとして何もわからなくなっちゃうんだよと
ただ古臭いものばっかり言うと
すごい気持ちよくなっちゃって聞くだけでしょうと
だから仏教は攻撃するのは
この人にある この精神的な頑固さ
変えようとしない その心
その精神 その硬さを激しく批判しているんですね
柔軟になりなさいよと
その方が楽ですよ そこで頑固以降ももう頭がもう悪いということだからね
何も変えたくないということは
何も変化もないし 何も進展もないし
何も進歩もないし 頭が悪くなる
それで思い浮かんだ一つのエピソードがあるんです
これは長部経典にあるエピソードなんです
で パーヤーシラージャンニャスッタという名前の経典なんですけど
この おそらくその経典というか
この出来事起きたのは
起きた時はお釈迦様はいなかったと思います
あるお坊さんにパーヤシという名前の
人なんですけど これラージャンニャと書いていますけど
この大王ではなくて 小さなどこか地方ですかね
治めていた まあ王みたいな人なんですね
だからラージャンニャっていうのはなかなか
ラージャは王と日本訳できますけど
ラージャンニャといえばこのもう大王だったら小王と言わないね
日本語で 小王か小王と言わないんですね
まあだから日本訳はできない
小さな王という意味でラージャンニャという言葉を使っています
あるいはプリンスという意味で訳してもよろしいしね
その人が このパーヤスさんが
すごい明確な人で 厳密に唯物論者なんですよ
彼が考えているのは 人間の体っていうのは
この世の中にある地水火風でできているんであって
それで死んじゃったら体が地水火風に戻る
それだけ もし誰かが人がね
道徳をするんだぞとかね
悪いことをするんだぞとかね
道徳をして天国に行くんだぞとかね
悪いことをして地獄に落ちるとと言ったら
それほどアホな嘘が世の中にないんだよと
死んだらもう体が壊れる
それで終わり というもう徹底しているんです
そこであるお坊さんがその国に行って説法するんだと言ったら
そのお坊さんが道徳の話とかね
言ってるんだから 話を聞いて
なんてアホな坊主ですかね
また来て人を騙そうとしてるんだと
自分の国民をね 言って一つ言ってあげるんだと言って
もうこのお坊さんを追い出したくて
大体唯物論者っていうのは宗教はすごい嫌いだからね
でもインドではやっぱり嫌いだからといってね
いきなりこの何て言いますか
刑務所に入れたりとかね
殺したりとかね そういうふうなことはしないんですね
一応 理屈で論理的に攻撃して
あんたが言ってることは間違ってるんだから
ちょっと出ていてくださいというふうな状態なんですね
それでこのパーヤスさんがそのお坊さんに会って
あんた本当ですかね？この人が死んじゃったら天国に行くんだとかね
あんただけじゃなくて
この宗教家がみんな言ってるんだよと
私はみんなインチキ嘘つきやと思ってますよ
と言ったら お坊さんが何のことなく
そう言わないで やっぱりいいことをした方がいいと思いますよ
悪いことをした方がしたら悪いと思いますよ
そういうふうに考えた方がいいんじゃないかと
言ったら彼が彼の研究を言うんですよ
で 私はもういろいろ研究して言ってるんですと
一つはこの人間が死んで地獄でも天国でも行くんだったら
この霊魂行かなくちゃあかんでしょうにと
それで私のところにこの犯罪者がよく捕まってくるんだと
それで私がこの犯罪者を死刑にするんだと
死刑にするとどうせ殺すんだから
霊魂が出ていくことはちゃんとチェックできるんだからね
ちゃんとチェックするんだと
これ一つ こう ある日 私は血一滴もこぼさないように
人を殺しちゃったんだ
その時は人を殺す前にちゃんと測ってみたんだと
体重をちゃんと測って
血一滴も出ていかないようにして
その人は窒息させて殺しちゃったんだと
処刑に決めた人だからね
殺してからその遺体を測ってみたんだと
遺体を測ってみたら なんと生きている時よりも死んだ時は重さ重いんだ
生きていた時は測った時よりもほんのわずか重くなったんであって
軽くなってないんだ それでもし魂があって
人が死んだところに魂が出ていったならば
もう魂の重さがないでしょうに
もう軽くなったんじゃなくて重くなったんだ
だからあんた方は嘘を言ってるんだと
そういう人殺したり もう一つ
この釜に入れて 釜に蓋をつけてシールを貼って
空気も出ないように それで殺しちゃうんですね
殺してあの蓋をすぐ割る
割った瞬間で見ているんだそうです
この霊魂が出ていくかと
見えなかったんですね
やっぱりないと それで決めるんですね
そういういろいろ研究したみたいですね
それでこのお坊さんの送った返事は
ある人が私に 私はあなたにもう一つ物語を言いますよと
ある人がこの大きなほら貝を見つかるんだと
見つけて そのほら貝でほら貝を吹くんだと
吹くとものすごい響く声が出てくるんだと
それで一人の馬鹿者がいて
なんて素晴らしい音ですかと
響くんだと 体までこの音に
このほら貝からこの音が出たんだと
ですから その音を探してみようかなと思って
ほら貝を持ってきて 上から見るは下から見ると中に目を入れてみるとか
でも見えません この音
どこにあるんでしょうね
でも最終的にはほら貝を破ってみるんだと
破ってみても その人には音は見つからないんだと
あんたどう思いますか？と王様に聞くんですよ
その人はすごい研究者だと思いますかと言ったら
その人は研究者ではなくてバカもんだよと
だってホラ貝の音っていうのは
人が自分で取って適当に口を合わせて吹かないと出てこないんだからね
ホラ貝の中の音はあるわけじゃないんだと
だから私も王様に言いたいんだけど
王様もそうやってね 人の魂を探しても同じことやと
王様にバカとは言ってないんです
それ 仏教のやり方 自分で言わせるんです
最初の例を出して で もう一つ例いるんですよ
私のこの親戚とかね いるんですよ
ものすごい悪い人々が
人は殺すは 女は奪うは
もうもうやりたい放題の悪いことをするんだと
それで私はしっかりと
このお坊さんたちの言うことは本当であるならば
この人々は地獄に落ちるんだと
ですから私はその親戚が死にかけていると行くんだよと
お見舞いに行ってこう言うんだと
あなたはね 生きている間はずっと悪いことをしたんだよ
だからあなたはこの出家者の話によると
地獄に落ちるんだと ですから地獄に落ちたならば私に言ってくれ
やっぱりあれは本当でしたと
地獄に落ちたんだよと
言ってくれと言ったら
その人々もちゃんと約束するんだと
はい わかりましたと申し上げますと
約束して死ぬんだけど
一度でも言ってくれたことがないんだと
だからあんた方は嘘を言うんだよと言ったら
このお坊さんの反論がね
じゃああなたに聞きますけど
あなたのところにこの犯罪者が来たら
あなたはもう裁く 裁くと言うんですか
して まあ例えば十年刑とかね
年刑とか何かに決める
あるいはもうすぐ処刑に決めると
打ち首にすると そうするとその犯罪者があなたにこう言うんだよと
王様 ちょっと待ってください
私の親戚がいて この親戚が私に忠告したんだよと
この泥棒をしたら 悪いことをしたら
あんたは殺されますよと
ですから もしそういうふうなことになったならば
私に言ってくれと そうすると私も泥棒しないで済みますよと
私は約束したんだから
私の親戚に だから王様
ちょっと待ってください
私は私の親戚にこれから私は殺されますよと言ってきますからと言ったら
あなたはその犯罪者を逃がしてあげますかと
ただとんでもないんだと
逃がすどころか もうその場で捕まって
もう刑務所に入れて首を切るんだと
もう親戚に会わせませんと
誰とも もう犯罪者だからと
だったら地獄に落ちたらどうやってあなたに報告するために来られますかと
もう犯罪者だから地獄から解放してくれないんだと
あんたにそれぐらいのことわからないんでしょうかと
それで王様は負けた 負けたくないだから逆にでも私の親戚の中で本当に道徳をする人もいますよと
すごくもう苦労しながらいい人生を役立っている人々
その人々がもう寝たきり
燃焼なときになったら
私はまた約束してもらったことはありますよと
あんた方はちゃんと天国に行くんだそうと
ですから 私もこれからでも人生直しますから
天国に行ったならば私に言ってくださいと言って約束して死ぬんだけど
一度も天国から来て報告したことがないんだと
ただ お坊さんの反論は
あんた一応天国の話 お坊さんの話
たとえインチキであるとも聞いたことがあるでしょうということで
天国の寿命は知ってますかと
一番低いレベルの天国にしたっても
人間の年が 1 日ですよと
人間の世界の年が向こうで 1 日ですよと
そこで天国に生まれた人が生まれた瞬間にあなたに報告するんじゃなくて
行ったところはちょっと周りを見て
1 日 2 日ね みんなの挨拶して
いや 王様にもちょっと報告しなくちゃいけないんだなと思って
あなたに報告する あんたどこにいるんですかと
もう向こうで 3 日挨拶回りしただけでも
こちら 300年経ってるんだから
そんな話でまあもう論争を続けたんだけど
それで王様が最終的にいくら言ってもお坊さんがね
やっぱり私はもう優越すら捨てませんと
そう言ったところで このお坊さんがこのもう決定的な例を言うんですよ
私にもう一つエピソードを思い浮かべますよと
このエピソードはどういうことかというと
あるものすごい貧しい村があって
その村の若者二人がね
やっぱり外へ出て稼ぎましょうと
一財産作って楽になりましょうと
二人が外へ出るんだけど
外へ出たら町を離れていくと
途中でこの日本語で何と言いますかね
まあ人の弁当かね それは外でやっちゃうと硬くなるんですよ
硬くなるし 臭くもないんです
それはすごいいい肥料なんです
あの便所のカスというものはね
干したならばね で それの山が見つかるんだと
そうすると この二人は自分たちのはもう 1円も 1文もない状態だからね
やっぱりこれ我々二人が袋に入れて持って行って
誰かこの畑作っている野菜作っている人に売って
ほんのちょっと何かもらいましょうと
これも商売になるんだと
ああ そういえばそうです
二人で大きな袋を二つ作って
これ頭に乗せて行くんです
価値があるんですよ いくら一日ぐらいの食べ物でも
それでね もらえるんだから
で行く途中で あの麻という草ありますね
そういう森に出会いますと
そうすると一人がこんなものを持って行って売ってもあんまり金になりませんと
でもこの麻を我々は切って束にして売っちゃえば
このもっと金になるんだよ
と言ったら 一人があんた何言うんですかね
私はどれぐらいこれ運んで遊んで歩いてきたと思いますかと
かなりきつかったと だからこれ何のことなく捨てろと言うんですかと
私は捨てませんよと そんな苦労は水の泡になるんだと
言ったらもう一人の友達がどうぞどうぞ言って
私は捨てますよと言って
あの袋を捨てて 麻を切って束にして運んでいくんです
途中でその生の麻ではなくて
水の中に落ちてもう腐ってる麻見つかるんで
いわゆる麻の繊維ですね
したらまたあの人言うんで
やっぱりこの麻よりは繊維持っていった方がもっと高く売れますよと言っても
一人が麻を捨てて繊維の束を持っていく
一人が元の袋だけ持っていく
苦労して持っていったんだから捨てません
苦労は水の泡になるんですから
それでどんどん進むんで
これストーリーだからね
次に綿に出会う 次に糸に出会う
綿の次にもう布に出会う
次に絹に出会う でも一人は絹の束を持っていて
一人は元のものを持っていく
で さらに行ったら 銀に出会う
金にも出会う 一人が銀に出会ったところ
全部捨てても布 布ではなくて絹
を捨てて もう金銀を持っていくんですね
それで金に出会ったところで
あれも捨てて金を持っていくんですね
一人が元のものは黒は水の泡にしたくないんだからね
持っていくんです それで最後に四方に宝山にぶつかるんですね
四方入っている それで一人がその 7つの宝物
いっぱいある宝石 種類ですけどね
それはもっと軽いんだから
それは束ねも袋に入れて持っていくんです
いて もう村に帰ろう で
村に帰る 村に帰る途中で雨が降るんです
雨が降って あの頭の上にあったものはどんどんもうもう水がついちゃって
溶けて溶けて体中もう指先までこのお仏が流れていくんだと
それで村人が誰のことを褒めるんでしょうか
誰が幸せになるんですかと
村人の立場から見れば
そのようにあなたもあなた
いくら私が反論しても
自分の古い考え方は捨てませんと
ですから どうぞご自由に自分の考え方で有名になってくださいとと言ったんです
そうしたら王様はそんなことはないんだと
私はあなたの最初の質問を聞いて
答えを聞いただけでも
あなた方の知恵にはもうびっくりしたんだと
ただあなたは体だけですよと
いろいろ例を出して 私は今日からちゃんとした因果法則を理解する
理解しますと これから仏教徒にもなりますと
ですから ちゃんと私に診療してくださいと
王様が一応仏教徒になって
ストーリーと経典が終わりますけどね
だから仏教は批判するのは動いているのは元のものを運んだ人の話なんですよ
だから仏教は変化に反対わけじゃないし
古臭いものでもないんです
科学反対ってわけでもないんです
真理を語っているんだから
仏教は怖くないんです
どんな科学を発展しても
どんな生物学 医学をいくら発展しても
DNA の研究はいくら発達したっても勝手にしてと
こちらは変わりませんと
こちらの方がもっと先に行ってるんだから
ですから 皆様も知っている通りに
この科学発展というのはみんな命かけてやったでしょうに
地球は丸いと言ったことで命がなくなっちゃったんだから
宗教というのはそれぐらいこの古いものを
守りたがっているんです
だから 人間の精神の頑固さっていうのは
この宗教の世界でよく見えるんですね
だから この変化に反対なのは宗教なんです
ブッダの教えではありません
それで この宗教があってもなくても
人間はどこかで宗教的なんですよ
時々日本のテレビなんかで
この若者の話なんかを聞いていると
もう何か物事うまくいった場合はまるっきり宗教と関係ない
全くのもう それでもやっぱり私は神様がいると思ってますよと
なんでかというと やっぱりこういうことをしたらうまくいきましたと
結局同じ馬鹿者でしょうね
私もやっぱり宗教も全部片っ端から否定しているんだから
まあなかなかいい現代人
若い者ではないかと思ったところであんなことを言っちゃうと
もう私はまあ同じ ということになっちゃうんですね
だから宗教がなくても
何かに頼って もう何かを信仰してというところが必ずあるんですね
だからそこがそのすごい心の頑固さなんですね
それで なんで人が死んじゃったら泣くんですかね
皆様 我々は人が死んでも泣きませんというかもしれませんだけど
まあそれはまあ死んでよかったというふうに思っている
早く死んでよかったと
という気持ちある場合は泣かないんですけど
やっぱり自分の親戚がね
おじい様がおばあ様が両親が大変ありがたいとね
愛情を持っていると 泣かせにはいられないと思いますけど
子供なんか病気になったらすぐ混乱する
あれ なんでしょうかね
それも同じことなんです
変わるのは嫌なんです
変わってほしくないんです
だから悲しみが生まれてくる
で 子供でも病気になったら
もうこれ嫌で嫌で それで落ち着きがなくなっちゃって
頭がもうパニック状態になって
まるっきり生きてる狂ってる人間になっちゃうんですね
だから子供には最初にするべき研究的なこともできないし
それで病院に行っても
そちらの人々に落ち着いて治療することもできないし
これいろいろ文句を言うんだから
結局問題は悪化する 落ち着いてその変化を認めたならば
いい結果になるんですよ
我々の落ち着きないのも
この変化は嫌嫌だと思っているんだからなんです
泣くのも変化が嫌だからなんです
悲しむのも変化が嫌だからです
よく見ていくと なんで悲しむの？はっきりしていますよ
何かが起きて悲しいでしょ
だから元の状態にいてほしいんですよ
例えば 恋人に振られたとしますね
それで悲しくなる だから
その人の悲しみを消すためには
振られた恋人がまたごめんなさいねとか言って
また仲直りしないと また元に戻れないと
悲しみが消えませんね
だから結局人間っていうのは
物事は変化するのは嫌なんですよ
いつでも元に戻りたいんですよ
この元って何でしょうかね
どこにあるんですかね
戻りたい元はどこにあるんですかね
どんどん元に戻ってみたら
赤ちゃんになるんでしょうね
もっと元に戻ってみたら
もう胎児になっちゃうでしょうね
もっともっと元に戻ったならば
もう生まれてもないんでしょうに
だから何言うんですかね
お金がなくなったらまあ悲しいと
なんで悲しい？やっぱり前はお金がいっぱいありましたと
だからそういうのを仏教では簡単にもうバカとアホと無知やと愚か者やと
このありえないことを考えているんですね
退化すること 元に戻ること
で そこは一番アホなことを言うのは宗教なんです
で 我々は元に戻りたいんだけど
元に戻る位置は考えてないんです
今のコンピューターにしたっても
コンピューターおかしくなったら元に戻す
という機能があるんです
いわゆるおかしくなる前の
元に戻れます でもその場合は
そのコンピューターを使う人が前もって戻る時点と時間を設定しておかないと Windows
ミレニアムでは動かないんです
ですから コンピューターはすごい元気で頑張って動く
動いてくれる場合は すぐその時間とその日にちをコンピューターに覚えさせておく
そうするとコンピューターが中にこのデータをね
記録しておいて おかしくなっちゃったらその時点に戻ってくださいと言ったら
すぐ新しく作ったプログラム全部捨てて
元に戻ってまた機能してくれる
だからそれはそれでいいんですけど
で 現代 一般的な人々はただ単に元に戻りたいと
というところで 一応アホなんですけど
元に戻れる時点はあるんですよ
子供が病気になったならば
まあ元気な時の泣き方考えて
そちらに戻りたいんだと
ありえないんですけどね
過去に戻ることは でもまあ一応まあまあしょうがないってぐらいは言えますね
でも宗教はそうじゃないんですよ
人間には本来の姿があるんだと
生命には だから私のこの宗教を修行すると
その人間が元の状態に
本来の状態に戻るんだよと
あれはどんな状態でしょうかね
だから皆様方 そういう話聞くとね
あの全テキストではもうなんとかすごい特別な発音でするんだから
超未然なんとかというふうに読み方漢字もわかりません
難しい漢字で  そんな言葉があるんですね
一般現代語で言えば 本来という言葉ぐらいですからね
悟りって何？なんぞやと言ったら
それは人の本来の状態だと
あれ 何なのかね 本来の状態っていうのは
だからもうただもう好き勝手にこのお祈り文句みたいな言葉使ってるだけでわかってないと思いますけど
元に戻るってありえないんです
赤ちゃんに戻って 胎児に戻って
もっと元に戻ると あり得るのは先へ行くことだけなんですよ
先へ行く それしかないんです
もう過去を忘れてしまえと
それ ブッダの堂々たる言葉なんですよ
いろんなところで聞こうってありますよ
過去はもうもう気にしないと
過去に囚われないんだと
過去は悩まないんだと
もう終わったんだからもういいでしょう
忘れちゃいます で 仏教はもう将来に対しても悩みませんですけど
一般の方々はちょっと先のことを考えたっても
これはもうしょうがないんですよ
私はいいとは言わないんで
しょうがないという言葉はもうわざと使ってます
ちょっと将来のこと心配だわとかね
ちょっと体のことはね
ちょっと心配そうとかね
いうのは私はまあしょうがないと思います
それで構いませんとは言いたくないんです
なぜならば 仏教はもっと厳密に
将来も気にせんでもいいやと
どうせ変わるんだから
放っておけばそのように変わるんだからね
それで私の 2番目のポイントで
そんなに変わる必要はあるかというところで
そんな苦労して変わらなくても物事は変わるんですよ
変わらないものは何一つもないんです
ですから 仏教はいうのは放っておけと
放っておいて その場でその場の条件に正しく適応する
寒いんだったらもう 1枚を着ると
あと暑くなったらその 1枚を脱ぐと
そうやってきちんと対応する
でもその対応もその場でその場でずっと持ち運ぶ必要はありませんと
ですから 本当はすべてのものは瞬間瞬間変わる
変わらないものはないんです
ですから 我々にはいつでも怠ける暇がないんです
ふざける暇がないんです
今日はもう二度と出てこないんですよ
だから今日 今の時間でも二度と出てこない
ですから その時間大事に真剣に有効に使う
たとえ皆様の腹が立ったっても
この話はちゃんと聞いた方が得をするんです
覚えた方が得をするんです
たとえ全く反対意見かもしれません
それでも得になりますよ
こんな変な話 もうまるっきりインチキな話
なんとか坊主は言いましたよと
それぐらいでも知識に加算されますからね
認めても認めなくても
ですから その時間でくだらんことをいろんなことを考えて考えて
家のことやら夜のご飯を食べようかとかね
息子は今何やってるんでしょうかとかね
そんなことを考えちゃうのは
もうそれがもう愚か者の生き方ですよと
時間の大事さがわかってないんだよと
時間っていうのは戻らないんだよと
で 私は皆様の寿命の大事な時間を取っちゃったんだから
もう二時半ぐらいからし始めたんだけど
そろそろ四時になります
そうすると何時間でしたっけね
[笑い] 計算が下手だから
ですから 皆様の寿命からね
一時間半 まあ私はもう取っているんですよ
もう戻りません もう年取っているんです
ですから その時間を無駄にしちゃうと
これはもうどうにもならん
もう取り返しつかない大変な損なんです
だから人間にはもう時間というものはずーっと流れています
それでお釈迦様のおいなる文句より綺麗な言葉があります
これ昔も書います 書きましたからね
お粥の会館で 私の悪いことでもほとんど覚えてるんです
[笑い]なんか長すぎみたい
読み方はアッチェンティカーラタラヤンティラッティヨ
ワヨグナーアヌプッバンジャハンティ
エータンバヤンマラネペッカマーノ
ローカーミサンパジャヘーサンティペイコ
それあの綺麗な節で覚えさせるために書いているものなんです
あの 下は読めないね まあ別にまあ覚えなくたって
アッチェンティカーラタラヤンティラッティヨ
ワヨグナーアヌプッバンジャハンティ
エータンバヤンマラネペッカマーノ
ローカーミサンパジャヘーサンティペイコ
アッチェンティカーラっていうのは
時間はもう過ぎ去る 時間はもうなんて言いますか
タイムイズパーシング
日本語でどう言えばいいんですか
ん？過ぎていく 時間は過ぎていく
タラヤンティラッティヨ
タラヤンティっていうのは同じ
ラッティヨっていうのは夜ですね
夜がもうどんどん過ぎていく
だから夜夜明けになるともう時間取っているんですよ
また朝になるとまたもう時間流れてるんですね
時間はずっともう過ぎ去っていくんだよと
それだけじゃない ワヨグナーアヌプッバンジャハンティ
時間は過ぎ去ると我々のワヨ
ワヨっていうのは寿命
グナーっていうのは体の健康やら体力やらね
能力とかそういうもの
寿命である寿命と我々持っている体力
能力などなどもアヌプッバンジャハンティ
徐々に消えていくと 夜明けになるともう徐々に消えている
また次の夜明けでまた消えていると
だからもうそんなにふざけて生きていられますかね
エータンバヤンマラネペッカマーノ
最終的には死んでしまいますね
だから死にますよと エータンバヤン
この怖いこと マラネ 死ぬことにすぎて
こんな落ち着いていられないこと
これ怖いことなの 考えてみれば
だって今若いんだけど
もう時間過ぎ去っていくんだから
若さが消えていくんですよ
今元気なんです それ消えていくんですよ
あまり面白い話じゃないんでしょうと
それがエータンバヤンマラネペッカマーノ
その死に対するその脅威を観察して
ローカーミサンパジャヘーサンティペイコ
世の中に対する執着を捨てて落ち着きなさいと
サンティペイコっていうのは
この平安を望む人がローカーミサン
世の中に対する世の中のいろんな物事ですね
対する執着 パジャヘー
捨ててください これあの歌としてすごい綺麗ですよ
まあ我々は自分の国だったらよく説法なんかにも使います
もう一つバージョンありますけど
これはもっと難しいバージョンで
4行目は変わります 簡単なバージョンでは
では そんなにあの そんなに今日のテーマにそんなに厳密に関係ということないんだけど
一応時間というのは瞬間
瞬間消えていく だから時間という今の瞬間を大事にしないと
その人ほど愚か者がいないんです
物事には後回しはできないんです
逆戻りもできません ですから
今精一杯明るく生きると
そうすると この変わる変わるということに引っかからなくてもいいんですよ
このローカーミサン 世の中に対する執着
捨てない執着 どういうことかというと
世の中の物に執着するということは
変化の反対派なんですよ
変わることの反対派なんですよ
お金に執着する人がお金消えることは嫌でしょうに
自分の体に執着する人が体が年取ることは嫌でしょうに
だからみんな執着しすぎ
だから若者も古くさいんですよ
ダサいんですよ 私から見れば
決して流行に乗ってるわけじゃないんです
私はあんまり面白いこと喋ってみたって
あんまりにも魔法らしくて
なんか新しいもの 刺激的なもの
何もないんです なぜかというと
あまりにも執着しすぎ
若者であっても 自分の体に
自分の持っているものに
遊びに執着しすぎ だから変化反対派なんですよ
だから変化に反対したら
そちらにあるのは限りのない苦しみ
それは親が死んだら悲しいでしょうに
子供が死んじゃったら悲しいでしょうに
その例で考えてください
子供が先に死んじゃったら
それは悲しい なぜならば自分が変化反対派なんです
でも 変化反対派っていうこと自体ほど
この世の中で無知な考え方がありません
なぜならば 宇宙も全てもう瞬間も止まることなく変わっていくんだから
だから私が言うのは 変わることが存在であって
永遠不滅の存在あるわけじゃないんです
永遠不滅っていうのは
愚か者の人間が論理わからないんだから
理屈わからないんだから
正しい理屈をね わからないんだから言ってる変な考え方なんです
何の根拠もないんです
永遠不滅という言葉には
存在は無常なんです 無常が存在なんです
宇宙があるんだっていうことは
宇宙がずっと変化しているということなんです
でないと成り立たないんです
私が生きているんだということが
私が変わっているんだということなんです
でなきゃ生きてないんですよ
生きているんだからご飯食べるでしょうに
生きているんだからお腹が空くでしょうに
生きているんだから疲れるでしょうに
だから生きてるんだってことが
私が変化しているんだ
変わっていくんだっていうことなんですよ
これ 単純な論理でわかりますよ
それなのに私が変わっても魂が変わりませんと
よく言うこと この変わらない魂はどこにあるんでしょうか？とお釈迦様は聞きたいんですね
だから何？だからお釈迦様はこうおっしゃるんですよ
ほんのわずかな ほんのわずかなものでも
この存在において変わらないものっていうのはあるんだったら
私がこの説法なんかしませんよと
心清らかにしなさいと言いませんよと
この全存在の中で ほんのわずかなものでも無常でないものがあるならば
私は解脱の道は語りませんと
それぐらいはっきりとおっしゃっているんです
すべては無常である 何の実体もないんだよと
ですから 仏教徒になるということが
変化は認める派になることなんですよ
だから変化を認めたくない
すごい頑固でいることが仏教の世界とは反対のなんですね
でも誰が苦しみかというと
その人々が苦しむ 何があってもどうせ起こるものだからね
そんなに気にする必要ないんですよ
何が起きても どうせこの中で起こるものが起こるんですよ
起こるべきでないものは起こるわけじゃないんです
人間に翼が生えてきたとか
角が出てきたとか 尻尾が出てきたとか
そんなことはありえないでしょうに
それだったらもう驚いたってもいいんですけど
泣いてもいいんだけど
でも人間が病気になるとかね
年取るとか 車運転間違って事故を起こしちゃうと起こしちゃうとかね
それぐらいのことでしょうに
そんなものはもうどうしてもあり得ることだから
避けられないことだから
だから楽になりたければ変化を認めること
で わざと強引に変化させようとすることは
そこのポイント ちょっと休憩取ってから喋りましょう
皆さんは大変疲れていらっしゃる
それで若い世代とかね
みんなこのいろんなものを変えようとしていますね
それについて で それもまあ変えるのはいいんですけど
そんなに驚くほどのことじゃないんですよ
我々の物事を変えよう
新しい流行を作ろうという
その衝動が頑固さから出てくるんです
結局はもう変えたくないという
そこから出てくるものなんですね
だから大したことじゃないんです
だからすぐもう変えても
すぐもう半年間でもう新しいものにまた変えてしまっちゃう
それは一つよく見えることで
だから変えることだけ考えれば
もう何でも変えられますからね
もう一つ 心の中で このすごくこの同じ
もうこの変えたくないという
この嫌なこの気持ちが出てくるんですよ
その気持ちにも反応して
もう状況を変えてしまう
それからつまらなくなりますね
例えば同じ色の服着ていると
同じ髪スタイルだったらつまらなくなっちゃうんですね
なんでつまらなくなるんでしょうかね
それは無常だからなんです
それでもっと面白くなろうと
もう変えるだけで それでもそれまたつまらなくなっちゃうんです
それでまた変えてしまうと
だからそういう変えて変えていくことで全然終わりがない
でも変えると言ったっても
もうそれほど変えることできないんですよ
だからある時期はかかとまでスカートは長いと
ある時期は膝のところになってくるんだと
ある時期は膝の上までいくんだと
お尻もちょっと見えるところまで短くなるんだと
またいきなりかかとまでくるんだと
またお尻まで上がる そればっかりなんですよ
いくらなんでもこの腰に巻くことだからね
それ以上何もできんでしょうに
だからそんな苦労して
だからみんな苦労してるんです
変えたいんだけど 変える選択肢はそれほどないんです
いくつしかないんです
新しい食べ物を食べたいという気持ちがあるんだけど
結局食べるものは毎日同じものなんです
そんな今日は鶏食べたんだから
明日ゴキブリ食べましょうとなりますかね
結局は今日はもう何と言いますか
もう油で揚げてなんとかして食べたんだと
まあ次はもう大判でなんとか焼いて食べましょうとかね
次はカレーにして食べると
同じ鶏なんですけど それで変わってると思ってるんです
結局食べてるのは同じものなんですけど
ご飯にして食べましょうとおかゆにして食べましょうと
チャーハンにして食べましょうと
おにぎりにして食べましょうと
だから面白いこと ああ
これが美味しい 同じご飯なんですけど
私にとっては全く同じで
別にどうったことないんですけど
そこであの店のチャーハンがすごくない
いえ この店のチャーハンがすごい
どんな店に行ってみたって同じなんですけど
だからそこで変わるんだ
変わるんだと チャーハン作る時は椎茸でも刻んで入れたら
これすごい大発明で料理研究家なんです
椎茸の代わりにワカメでも入れたら
あまりチャーハンにワカメ入れたことは見たことないでしょうに
ワカメでも刻んできたら
あれすごい違う変わったチャーハンでしたねとかね
そんなもんですよ もう帰ったって
もうだからもう帰りたいんだけど
それほど選択肢がないんです
選択肢がないんですよ
だからそんなそんなものにそんなにこのとらわれる必要もないし
でも自由な心を持っていけば
人をびっくりするほど変化はいくらでも考えられます
ある人が私のところに来てご飯食べてないんですね
で 私は料理は作りませんだけど
まあなんか訳があって
この前の日豆腐買ってあったんですね
で 私は日本食はできませんだから私は人に作ってあげる場合はカレー作ってあげる
自分にはそれには自信がありますからね
下手な料理作って食べさせて人のお腹壊すよりは
相手には口に合わなくてもまともな料理作って食べさせたいんです
ですから この私はどこかに行くといったら
そちらの人々は本を買ってきて勉強してカレー作ってくれるんですね
あれはちょっとした まあありがたい
ありがたいねなんですけど
自分に上手におにぎり抜きれるんだったら
それで私はすごい美味しく感じますけど
本人がそこら辺でプロだからね
この初心者で試しに 作る
で カレーの味よく知ってる人に食べさせちゃうとね
まあそれは置いておいて
ですから 私は一応カレー作りましょうと思ったら
カレー カレーはいいですよね
私は豆腐しかないんだけどと
豆腐のカレーどうですかと
あんた何言うんですか？変でしょ
そんなことは そんな食べられませんと
豆腐のカレーなんかできっこはないんだと
ああそう じゃあ見てみろと言って
日本の風なカレーではなくて
我々の伝統的なカレーの作り方で
自分の国では豆腐はありません
一種類あります すごい硬い
この向こうは暑い国だからね
だからこのものすごい硬く干した豆腐はあります
それもあのゴーヤ豆腐とは違います
すごい硬い もう食べ食べられたもんじゃないんです
ですから もう でも私は作ったんです
作って まあ本人も最初から嫌な顔をして食べ始めました
どうですか？なかなかうまくいくんですねとかね
不思議ですよと こんなにもよくうまくいくますよと
だからもう大胆な思考でやれば
何のことなくできます
でもソフトクリームのカレーはできません
だから私 それ頼んだっても
ソフトクリームのカレー作ってくださいって
でもそれはちょっとできません
カレーに入れてあげることはできますけど
ですから まあ思考を自由にしておけば
もういつでも面白いことはできるんですよ
だから 人々の新しいもの
新しい流行を作る 作ると言ったっても
そんな仏教徒が驚くほど困るほどのものじゃないんです
すごい単純なことなんで
だから心を自由にしていけば
仏教徒であるならば 決して流行に遅れません
遅れるどころか もう一歩先にいることもできます
で 昔 結構若者とかのもう
まあ付き合うことをいっぱいやりましたからね
みんな流行に乗ってるんだけど
私はあんまりダサいやと
これ古臭いやと あんたこういう風に変えたらどうですかと色々デザインとか言うんですよ
言ってもそんなことやったらダメ
なんでダメですか？いや
これは決まりですから
このスタイルは決まりですから
だからなんで決まりと流行っていうのは紙合わない言葉でしょうに
紙合わない 昔 自分の国の若者たちが
男たちが髪の毛を伸ばすということを首のところまで伸ばすこと
長さがはっきり決まってるんです
そこで格好良かろうが悪かろうか
もう流行に乗ってる人々は首のそこら辺まで髪を伸ばしてるんですね
それからみんな男たちがそんな感じだから
もうあんまり面白くないんですね
私はあれもそれはやめたらどうですかとね
髪の毛は周り あんたもうものすごく大きいんだからね
髪の毛ありすぎて そこら辺はちょっと切って
これを一つ結んでおけばいいんですか？と
で 怒られたんです そんなことはもう決まりじゃないんだと
あんたわからないんだと
今の流行はと あ そうと
でも後でいくらでも見たんですよ
男の人は髪の毛を何かバンドで結んでいるのは随分最近ですけどね
私は行ったの３０年前
まあですから もう思考をちょっとね
そうすると その私の話を聞いたならばね
その男の子 男の子だけでも
みんなの間で全く別に変わって見えるでしょうに
だから変わりたいんだけど
変わって見えてほしくないという
この馬鹿馬鹿らしさが
何でしょうかね 変わり者っていうのは批判の言葉でしょうに
言って流行に乗っているんだと
だから流行に乗りたければ変わり者でいいんですよ
でも変わり者は嫌で でも流行にも乗っていたいんだと
乗り遅れたくないと  そういうアホな人の話には話は気にする必要ないんです
落ち着けばいいんです
どうせ物事は変わるんです
どうせ変わるんです 頑張っても頑張らなくても
知識も変わる 全ての流行も変わる
科学もなんだかんだ変わる
変わるもんだなと思っておけば
気楽に生きていられます
そこでこのもう一つ変わり方がありまして
新しい食べ物を新しい薬と調べては飛んで食べる
飛んで行って買う ということはあるでしょ
みんなもう新しい変わり者やと思ってますけどね
今の店に売ってる豆腐は食べませんと
これはどこかでなんとかの方法で作っている豆腐しか私は食べませんと
私はもうどこかのある地方で
こういう農業の方法で作っているご飯しか食べませんよとかね
そうやって普通の人と違っているものをものをやっているような感じで
食べ物と薬と栄養剤とかね
そういうものに飛ぶ人々がいますけど
あれは変わり者でもなんでもないんです
とにかく自分の健康はそのまま維持したいんだと
いわゆる元に戻りたいという頑固のなんです
だから私は毎日食べるものしか食べませんよという
たとえ体に悪いと言っても
新しいものを食べませんという人に
我々は頑固なと言うでしょ
逆に新しいものばっかり食べる人も
それが健康に それが健康にという話でやっているんだから
もう頑固者には何の変わりもないんですね
どちらでも人間というのは頑固者なんですよ
だから変わりたくないという気持ちで
どうせ変わるのに 苦労しているんです
だから これは猿で水を運ぶことと同じなんですよ
いくら苦労したっても意味がないんですよ
もう逆らえないんです
だから全てのものは変化するんだから
それを理解して落ち着けば
それで流行に乗っているんです
それでこの強引に物事変わってもいいんですけど
いろんなものをね でも人間がこの怒りと欲と無知はね
それが頑固の原因だからね
怒りと欲 無知を正当化する変わるものがあまり良くないんですよ
できるだけ欲が少なくなる
変わる方に世界が変わる
経済システムも変わる
困らなくても 執着しなくても
欲張らなくても生きていられないように変わるということだったらいいんでしょう
世界は怒らない世界に変えればどうですかね
一向にそういう変わり方はないでしょう
みんなとにかく差別感で国と国が争う
平気で嘘を言う 例えば中国をいじめたいんだから
平気でもうインチキはいいところ
例えば自分たちには国の領域の中にまで入ってスパイ活動する権利があるんだと
中国には威嚇する権利はないんだと
どんな理屈ですかね それが
お互いに話し合ってやめればいいでしょうに
いろんな国々に迷惑かけることが
そこでソ連がアフガニスタンに炎上していたんだからといって
日本もオリンピックも参加しなかったでしょうに
あれ どんな思考ですかね
言って  それでアフガニスタンはタリバンが一応取ったでしょうね
ソ連の方が負けたでしょ
誰に国をあげたんですかね
ただの原始野蛮人でしょうに
仏像を壊すは 女の人の教育は禁止するは
外へ出てはいけないというは
男はみんな髭を生やっていかなきゃいけない
仕事がなくなるは 髭なかったら
そういう原始人に国を与えただけでしょうに
言って中国を戦略することでも
もうユダヤ人がパレスチナ人に爆弾を落とす
それはいいんです だから屁理屈もいいところで
悪いものは誰がやっても悪い
人の権利を奪ってはいけない
だから新しい思考だったら
なんで世界を平和にしましょうかと
なんでそういう思考に来ないんですかね
人類はみんな平等だから
みんな同じ兄弟だから仲良くしましょうという
なんでそういう思考に変わらないんですかね
私の神こそ素晴らしい
あなたの神は神ではないんだと
そういうもうもうもう想像もできない嘘を言ったりして
なんで喧嘩するんですかね
だから変わる変わるで言ったっても
こんな変わり方ってなんの意味もないんですよ
欲と怒りをどんどん増える
政府スケールで嘘を言う
２０年経たないと それは嘘であることはバレないと
秘密だと なんで国に秘密はあるんですかね
だからこの変わるったければ
仏教から言えるのは やっぱりむさぼり
怒りをなくす生き方をしましょうと
それが本当の変わり方ですよと
だって我々はむさぼりと怒りと無知の塊でしょうに
だから頑固でしょうに
だから柔軟性がないでしょうに
敵を愛することはできないんですよ
嫌な人にもどうか幸せでありますようにと祝福することはできないでしょうに
自分に邪魔している人に対しても
どうかどうか気をつけてくださいと
人々が心配してあげることできますか？自分の足を引っ張ろうとしている人に対しても
それが本物の変わりなんですよ
本当の変わり者なんですよ
敵にもご飯作ってあげる
たとえ敵であろうとも
病気になったら真剣に看病してあげる
我が子のように慈しみで見る
それが本当の変わることなんですよ
だから私から言えば もう誰も変わってないんです
ただ頑固者で だから この現代世界で見られる変わるということが
仏教から見ればなんて面白くない
なんとも面白くない 変わるんだったら大胆に変わってほしい
人間にできないほどのことに変わってほしい
みんな驚くほどに変わってほしい
なんて人ですかと そこまであんた変わりますかと
人をびっくりさせるほどに変わってほしい
それをお釈迦様がやってみせたんです
いまだにその智慧にはみんなびっくりするしか
もう理解できないほど難しいんです
難しくはないんだけど
ブッダの教えは 我々は頑固だから理解できないだけで
それが本当の変わることなんですよ
ワンパターンで生きていることじゃないんだ
我々はずっとこの動物と同じく
この感情で生かされているだけ
生きているわけじゃないんです
欲が出てきて 何か動けと言ったら動く
欲の感情が出てきて あれ取れ
これ取れ あれ儲かる これしなさい
あの服を買いなさい 言っちゃうと
奴隷みたいに欲の奴隷で言うことをやってあげる
それで私は結果流行に乗ってるんだよと何言うんですかね
ただの奴隷でしょうに
それで怒りがあるでしょうに
怒りが出てきたらもう何でもすると
それで自分が変わり者やと言われるので
変わり者でもなんでもないんで
ただ怒りの奴隷なんです
ですから ずっと生命っていうのは動物も同じく貪瞋痴の衝動で生かされているんですよ
この生かされてという言葉というのは
結局結局いい言葉じゃないんですよ
すごいもう品のない言葉なんです
生かされててありがたいと
何がありがたいんですか？アホじゃないんですか？生きていなさいと
生かされているということは
言葉を変えれば飼われているという意味でしょうに
日本文化ではすごいありがたい言葉なんですけど
生かされているんじゃなくて
生きてみなさいよと 自分で
これはブッダの教えなんです
ですから 我々は結局生かされ飼われているだけ
貪瞋痴に飼われている
偉い人に飼われてるんだったらいいんですけど
飼われてるのは貪瞋痴に飼われているんですよ
だから生きることは苦労が多いだけなんです
ですから お釈迦様はこういう言葉で
ニヒーヤティプリソ ニヒーナ・セーヴィ
プリソ 人がニヒーナ・セーヴィ
卑しい人と付き合う 卑しいというのは
まあね すごい品のない
ものと付き合うと ニヒーナ・セーヴィ
ニヒーナというのは卑しいという意味なんですね
ものすごくもう優れているという言葉の反対ですね
そういう卑しいのものと付き合うと
ニヒーヤティ 卑しくなっちゃいますよと
堕落するんだよ だから貪人に貪人地に変われていることをありがた...ありがたがっても
結局堕落するだけなんです
ですから この これまた途中で二行ありますけど
それ抜けて四行目書きます
これはすごい このモットーとしてもいい言葉ですよ
で あのタスマっていうのはですからという意味で
アッテノウッタリン 自分より優れているものでも人でもいいんです
自分より優れている人をバジェト
人と付き合いなさい なぜかというと
卑しいものと付き合うと堕落するんだから
自分より優れているものと付き合いなさい
それは人でもいいし 性格でもいいんですよ
例えば 自分には怒りがあると
怒りが卑しいものでしょうに
怒りがすごい尊いわけじゃないでしょうに
憎しみ 嫉妬 怒り それは心にあるんだから
それは心で養っちゃうと卑しい人になってしまっちゃうんですから
その代わりに慈しみという優れているものと付き合う
それは性格の場合は 人の場合でも
自分よりいつでも優れている人々付き合ってみてくださいと
どんどん変わってきますよ
その場合はいい方向へ
まああの もうたくさんありますからね
もう今日私は用意したものからはね
一行 二行しか使ってないんです
全部パーリって もうパーリ経典から持ってきたんだけど
それからこの 物事を変わる勇気とかね
まあ変わりたくないということは
やっぱり怠けであってね
まあそれはもう 良くないし
やっぱり変わる勇気が必要なんですよ
我々 勇気っていうのは
我々本来頑固だから 本来ものすごく変わりたくないという妄想概念にも縛りつけているんだから
だからきつく ものすごい硬い柱に
もう鎖で体中を巻かれて巻いてるんですね
動かないんです 変わるということは
指をそっと動くぐらいのことだからね
ですから 我々の心は貪瞋痴そのもので
それに変われている だから
いくら我々変わった変わったと思ったっても
貪瞋痴が増えるだけで
それで苦しみが形変わって増えて増えてるだけで
幸せにはならないんですね
ですから 変わりたければ必要なのはと
いうと どこかにありました
うん うん この心の状態はこういうお釈迦様
これお釈迦様の専門用語なんですけど
2つの言葉 アーランベ
ダート ニッカマ ダート
パラッカマ ダートという 3つなんですね
これはあの ある特別な
この心にあるエネルギーなんですね
これどういうことかというと
やっぱり何かやりたいという気持ちがあっても
どうも腰が上がらないんですね
やる気にはならないんですね
その あ こういうこういうこと
じゃあやりましょうかと言って
この立ち上がる機能なんですよ
行動に移る この心の働きなんですね
ですから このダートというのは
この根拠 エレメント 基本的なパワーなんですね
アーランダっていうのはスタートする
開始するという意味 何でもこのスタートする
開始する この精神的なパワーを育ててほしいと
それ育てる方法は何でしょうかって聞いて
方法ないんです ただやるしかないんです
で ニッカマっていうのは
もうやって途中でやめるんではなくて
続けると 途中ででも まあ嫌だ
やめたということになるんですね
気持ちが弱くなるんですね
やっぱりいいこと始めたらやっぱりやり続けてみます
それがね パラッカマっていうのは
それを全部まとめてすごい勇気ということ
勇気には仏教では違う言葉なんですけど
パラッカマっていうのは並ならぬ勇気っていう意味なんですね
普通の勇気にはヴィリヤと言うんですよ
精進 パラッカマという場合は
もうこの並の精進 努力ではないんです
かなり 頑張らないと それはお釈迦様は何に思ってますか？心にある
この この怠け 変わりたくない気持ち
この心の頑固さ それを破るためにこの 3つ必要ですよ
だから口を開けて口に餌が落ちるまで待っていたっても来ないっていう
だから頼る宗教は そういう頼る世界はね
なんとかして前した前と
で 待っていると言っても
やはり自分でやらないと
本当かどうかわかりませんだけど
この我々の国のある普通の一般的な言葉遣いですけど
なんとかの名前の鳥なんですけど
水は飲まないんだ 飲めないんだと
くちばしはもうちょっと平らみたいなものなんですね
それで水が飲みたいんだ
飲みたい時はもう飲めないんだから
とにかく雨が降るまでまで待たなくちゃあかんと
そこでいつでも口を開けてるんだと
なんで口を開けてるんだというと
この雨が降って水でも落ちてくれれば飲めるのにということやと
だから それで我々にこの子供の頃ね
かなり親にそんな話をしてね
お前らなんで怠けるんですかということの言われたことなんですけど
私は本当にその鳥はそんな馬鹿かとわからないんだけど
水が必要だったらすぐ飲まなきゃね
おそらく昔の人々がその鳥なんか見たら
その鳥が常に口を開けてる習慣があったかもしれません
それに仏教的な言葉を入れちゃって
仏教はもう神に祈るそれが反対だからね
あの鳥もなんかもう空から落ちてくるまで待ってるんだよという
もう解釈したでしょうと思います
だから それは仏教はもう我々
私にも言われたんだからね
もう怠けると ...なんとか鳥みたいにね
待ってるんじゃないよと
自分で頑張る 頑張って
自分でやりたいことは自分でやるんだよと
ですから この変わる勇気を与えた前ではなくて
変わる勇気は自分で作るんです
自分で変わるんです それしか方法はないと
そこで物事が変わるために勇気が出てくるもう一つの方法っていうのは
すべてはどうせ変わります
心配する必要はないんです
何にも だからすべてのものは変わるんだから
何か変わったんだから大変だ
大変だという その気持ちは要りません
ですから 諦めるという 2番目の漢字ありますね
このタイトルに 諦めるという意味は理解するって意味なんです
こちらこそ読みます 諦めるっていうことは
本当に理解する 何を理解するかというと
すべては変わると 無常であると
ですから このカタカナで諦めと書いたのは
これを腰抜けの生き方
何にも勇気なし もう頑張れないんだと
もうダメやと その諦めではなくて
もう物事は変わるんだよということを理解しておきなさいと
そうすると何も怖いものはなくなるんです
勇気が出てくるんです
で 時間はもうあまりにも残酷的に過ぎ去ったんだから
もうそこら辺で話を締めさせていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]